did you see that um the uh amount of
weddings had dropped like massively
because of covid in Japan yep really
yeah oh and then people were freaking
the government was like for [ __ ] sake
we're already having a hard time getting
goddamn babies we didn't need people not
getting married and [ __ ] for two
years this is awful wait wait people not
getting married or people not having
weddings well people don't have well
because you can get married in Japan but
not have a wedding oh well I'm getting
married oh getting married going out a
meeting yeah oh yeah yeah yeah people
weren't going out people weren't going
to bars to meet their co-workers they
eventually fall in love with have two
babies good yay government likes that
yeah so now they're like for [ __ ] sake
what is happening now how do we get
people to go out because people now
people even even though you can go out
and Yeah and have a fun time and there's
still a lot of people who aren't going
out yeah um so now Japan has another
battle it's like now we've got to get
them to go out one reason YouTubers I'm
just kidding
YouTuber apocalypse
all right I told you I was wrong that's
not [ __ ] true now everyone is
watching YouTubers yeah well but I mean
would not say that that is a mass part
of it though no no no I mean
yeah
as as someone who used to watch a lot of
YouTubers I also I think a global
pandemic was a much bigger Factor but I
mean like yeah I'm not saying it's the
number one reason facials they're made
YouTubers sorry Japan babies I never
said that was the number one reason I'm
aware that there was a pandemic
I didn't come out of a rock and be like
damn btube is really [ __ ] ruined the
wall
I'll never forget that I'll never
forgive the YouTubers
what are you what are you okay as as
this is fun this is a fun little thing
okay so okay your Japanese doesn't count
what do you well you can do it there or
from uh from The Foreigner perspective
how do you think Japan has to fix their
their not having babies in one simple
solution not immigration because they're
never gonna do it [ __ ] you know you knew
what I was about because literally
because it was the obvious song
they're like oh hey Japan you know
there's this really easy cheat effects
that will solve your uh your your
declining uh population right yeah and
they're like oh what is it they're like
I'll just let immigrants in all right no
what is it they're just like did you
know there's a lot of people outside
Japan that yeah really want to [ __ ]
Japanese people
you know I mean yellow fever's kind of a
thing just saying he could say that
one I was just like he's the only one
out
if my dad didn't go Japanese people kind
of hot I wouldn't be here so I think I
have the Liberty to say that is your dad
like into Japanese women is that like
why or is it just oh yeah no he was like
I went to Japan one time and I got
yellow fever
that's why though there are so many
hafus out there because because my dad
isn't the only one so Japan Japanese
people are hot what Japan has made it
very clear that that they do like
because they their solution has been
proposed yeah to them many times yeah of
course yeah and they've constantly been
like we'll finally it's like yeah but
what's the real organism initially it
was like we'll just make robots
and like turns out that Robo technology
is like you know because they've been
making these robots since like the 90s
like companion robots yeah it's like the
90s and they just don't [ __ ] work
like they don't they don't solve the
problem and they it's been shown in
downtown again this is not going to
happen anytime soon yeah so you need to
think of something else so they're
they're I I literally can't think of a
word you know what's interesting
actually just yeah I think they're
[ __ ] like I think they're down until
they let immigrants in yeah the the
problems no no I was going to say like
coincidentally I started watching uh
this show on Netflix Called Love is
Blind do you know this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the Japanese one have you seen
the Japanese I've seen that I've seen
the Japanese one it's like not gonna I'm
a fan now what do you like about it it's
just like okay so here's the thing I I
watched back to back the American
version of love is blind and then I
watched the Japanese version of Love is
Blind all right yeah so explain the show
love is blind is this is this TV reality
show where uh a bunch of guys and a
bunch of girls who are looking for love
come uh they
they all come to these like this house
and and the males are separated with the
females and basically you go into what
they call pods basically and you talk to
if you're a guy you talk to a bunch of
girls and if you're a girl you talk to
all the guys yeah but you never see
their face until you propose
very very radical show right so you go
from not seeing each other to propose it
and so it's basically the whole concept
is you don't fall in love with the
person because of how they look you fall
in love with the person because of who
they are on the inside so what's the key
difference between the American big key
difference right watching the Japanese
one is like watching the best [ __ ]
romance anime you'll ever see because
it's so it is 100 just wholesome [ __ ]
the moment the moment the doors open and
this guy and girl who has fallen in love
with each other's personalities see each
other for the first time and they're
just like like it just lights up and
they you know like awkwardly hug and
[ __ ] like that it's like oh now we're a
husband and wife it's so [ __ ]
wholesome yeah the one American episode
I watched it's [ __ ] clearly this guy
just came back from alpha con because he
just like grabs the girl's ass and is
like I can't wait to get in that
in that fight I was like oh my [ __ ]
God you are just that one statement has
just completely ruined this building
this is why every romance anime ends
when they kiss yeah right this is why
they never go farther in romance anime
yeah and then in every American rom-com
they go to the [ __ ] and um it's just
like so like when I saw that I was just
like that might be a good thing because
I feel and this is just completely from
how I see it I think a big problem with
Japanese dating culture is that the
Japanese Society has kind of and
especially a lot of like TV and media
has kind of built up this weird stigma
around how someone looks yeah right
because like the the the the you know
the whole thing of like how Japanese
people need to be like really skinny and
like you know very fashion oriented they
all need to look like pretty and stuff
like that it's all a lot of like outside
right walks right which you know if
anyone has ever dated anyone would know
that can only get you so far yeah right
and I think because by but you know for
a lot of people the first step to
finding a partner is you know
unfortunately for a lot of people it's
like if you're not hot then I don't even
want to try kind of thing and I feel
that mentality that toxic mentality is
really sunken in deep in Japan yeah
because of things like Idol culture
because of the high fashion standards
because of the high you know like just
high standards soy boys the soy boys
basically I just think like it's like I
was trying to say like the problem is so
deep-rooted that you can't just point at
one thing of course like like the first
barrier I think of is that uh where do
people find time to meet people that's
the other thing that's just that's just
one of the barriers because well people
are gonna have to find time out of their
work so the first thing you're gonna
have to fix like one of the things
you're going to fix is just the
overworked culture in Japan because no
one [ __ ] has time to meet people here
um and then on top of that there's like
seven different other barriers yeah that
are just within the Japanese Society
there you have to go past and
unfortunately making one anime about to
Dad and a cute daughter is not gonna
[ __ ] fix all that you know like you
know you can make [ __ ] 10 spikes
families but that's not going to fix the
underlying problem unfortunately yeah I
can find depressing that like they think
of every other solution except like like
the obvious one yeah they just they
always just do it like you know make a
robot that loves you instead or you know
go make a call line where you can just
call someone to love you or go to a host
club and talk to a girl it's like
literally like they they just it's I I'm
just it's baffling that
even though the lengths like the whole
rent of family things right even that
that's an extension of that it's like it
it just perplexes me how they will
explore every Avenue that is not just
like hey just like people have like an
extra hour off work like let them let
them try and meet people or hey maybe as
uh maybe when they're kids we should
maybe focus on uh making them be like
have social skills or talking more
instead of ramming exams that are down
their throat to death I think with the
kind of change you would need to do this
it's kind of like a generation oh oh
dude like way more than that I think I
think it's like multiple Generations I
think at this one it is probably it's
just a cultural thing because yeah it is
like a lot of this is not because like a
lot of this is ingrained within Japanese
culture it's not the in Japanese culture
to you know not find a partner but a lot
of the of the effects I've seen within
Japanese culture this is one of the
results of that you know
um yeah that's uh that's a whole [ __ ]
web to untangle and I wouldn't even know
where to begin with that aside from just
let's just uh let more people come in
the country yeah it's it's fairly simple
Japan is just full of a bunch of
herbivores right so let the carnival
foreigners come in and just take them to
town did you
let the alphas come in dude there's not
enough Alphas in this country